[Music]
Kylie Jenner parties in pink with her
famous sisters all right guys
Kylie's launched us to wear pink
so rink on Tuesday the 21 year old
beauty mogul invited her nearest and
dearest to join her as she launched her
new skincare line in LA naturally most
of the kardashian-jenner crew was in
attendance including Kim Khloe and
Kourtney as well as her brother Brandon
her mama Kris
and her dad Caitlyn
[Music]
also in attendance James Charles Patrick
Starr candy Johnson and even a Jordan
woods look-alike named Heather Sanders
guests at the party were treated to a
menu full of some seriously tasty treats
including cheese fries pizza and noodles
[Music]
highly even kept the pink theme running
through the night with some of the
snacks including the cupcakes and even
the sushi this party was an instagramers
dream not only was her pink bathtub that
party goers could go pose it up in but
there was also a roller rink and Kylie
was all about it that was a pretty risky
bet to make considering that Forbes
dubbed Kylie the youngest self-made
billionaire when et caught up with Chris
Kendall and Kim in 2018 they said she
deserves the high honour she made her
own money for over a decade she put it
in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well
not like that was handed to her she
figured that all out and with the launch
of her new skincare line guys I think it
is safe to say Kylie's Empire is about
to get a whole lot bigger of course
we'll be here to keep you up to date on
all things Kylie so be sure to keep it
locked on e t until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now